I have no scheduled lectures about my
new book,
12 rules for life and other associated
issues in 12 different cities in the
next three months.
The first talk in New York takes place
at the end of March.
The remaining 11 occur in May.
There will be more venues in the UK,
Europe and Canada announced very soon.
Here are the cities and dates that have
already been booked.
New York Sunday,
March 25th Toronto,
Thursday May 3rd Washington Friday,
May 4th Chicago,
Saturday,
May 5th Detroit Sunday,
May 6th Denver Tuesday,
May 8th San Francisco,
Wednesday,
May 9th Seattle Thursday May 10th London
Sunday May 13th Dallas Wednesday May
30th Austin Thursday May 31st Phoenix
Friday,
June 1st tickets were on sale for my
patrion subscribers and viewers who have
signed up to my mailing list at Jordan
B.
Peterson Dotcom until today except for
New York.
The first show tickets are available to
everyone for all cities as of 10:00 AM
local time today,
Friday,
February 23rd for New York at the beacon
theater.
Tickets will be available to everyone as
of 11:00 AM local time today.
Friday,
February 23rd thank you for all your
continued support.
I'm looking forward to seeing you in the
next few months.